نتابع من مدينه غازي عنتاب مراسل الجزيره
عمر حوراني ايضا نعود اليك عمر
لمتابعه
الاوضاع التي تشهدها هذه المدينه في ضوء
الجو العاصف
والمثلج وهي المتضرره ايضا من هذا الزلزال
المدمر
نعم حسن ما زلنا نرصد الاوضاع الانسانيه
الصعبه التي يعيشها هنا سكان هذه المدينه
جراء هذا الباب كما نشاهد
سادع الصوره لكي تشاهدوا هؤلاء من
المدنيين اختاروا ان يبقوا هنا في هذه
الثلوج
واشعلوا النيران هنا في هذه الحدائق وذلك
لتخوفهم من حدوث
هزات ارتداديه كالتي حدثت طهر هذا اليوم
نحاول رصد الاوضاع الانسانيه منذ حدوث
الهزه الاولى هذا هذه هذه الليله وكان كل
مره رصدناه مؤلم حسن كان هناك لنا مشاهدات
للحظه لحظه حدوث الزلزال وفيما بعد كيف
راينا الناس والاطفال خرجوا من المنازل
دون ان يجهزوا انفسهم هذا الطقس كما تشاهد
الثلوج ما زالت تغطي هذه اعرف مناطق وايضا
هناك
اخرى تتجلى في هذه الابنيه التي سقطت
تنقلنا في اكثر من موقع وكان هناك ماسي
كبيره واكثر كنت قد وصلت الى احد الابنيه
وكان كنت اسمع اصوات لشخص او شخصين كانوا
يطلبون
المساعده من تحت الانقاض وايضا كانت
ماساويه تلك اللحظات التي يصل من ذوي
هؤلاء الاشخاص الى محيط هذه المبادئ رصدنا
عدد من البباني رفضنا عمليات الانقاذ
وسيارات الاسعاف كنا نشاهد بعض الضحايا من
تحت هذه الانقاض وحتى هذه اللحظه هناك
عمليات
انتشار للضحايا ومحاوله رفع انقاض الا حجم
دمار كبير حدث في بقعه واسعه تدمر عدد
كبير من المباني والفرق تعمل الا ان حجم
الماساه اكبر من هذه الفرق وحجم تلبيه
متطلبات
الاهالي هي لا تغطي حجم الكبير فنحن نتحدث
عن بان جميع سكان هذه المناطق هم الان
خارج منازلهم كان هناك حديث عن
لرئيسه بلديه غازي عنتاب ووجهت الاهالي
باتجاه التجمعات التي تم اعدادها من من
صالات رياضيه ومساجد والا ان الا ان
الاعداد كبيره وهناك الكثير مثل هؤلاء
الذين يتواجدون هنا في الحدائق يصوب عليهم
قد يصعب عليهم الوصول الى الى هذه الى هذه
التجمعات وسط ازدحام السير هناك جانب
انساني صعب ايضا رسدناه
الكثير او معظم السكان قضوا الساعات
الماضيه منذ حدود الزلزال في سياراتهم من
حالفه الحظ لديه سياره يحمل عائلته بها
يعني يوفر لهم الدفع بهذا الجو الجو
القارص وايضا يعني لكن ايضا شاهدنا هناك
حاله ارتباك يعني الكثير من الناس لا
يعلمون الى اين يتوجهون الا انهم يحاولون
الابتعاد عن الابنيه خوفا من حدوث
هزات ارتداديه كانت حدثت الحزه الاولى
وكان هناك عشرات الهزات تجاوزت المئه لكن
ظهر اليوم ايضا كان هناك هزات كبرى يعني
ضربت هذه احد ضربه هذه المنطقه وهذه
الهزات
هناك حديث عن استمرار هزات لكن لن تكون
الحديث ان لن تكون بحجم الهزات الكبرى
التي حدثتها هذه الامر والحديث عن الذات
ارتداديه تجعل
الاهالي هنا يقيمون في هذه الحدائق
ويشعلون هذه النيران ليكسروا شيء من من
البرد
ايضا من الجانب المؤلم ان هناك الكثير من
الاطفال هنا متواجدين مع ذويهم في هذه
الحدائق وكل
شاهدنا مشاهد مؤلمه جدا عندما خرجنا في
لحظه الزلزال كان هناك الكثير من الاطفال
لم يرتب هذه الاجواء وذلك لانهم ارعوا على
على عجل كان باغتنا الزلزال انا اسكن فيه
هذه الولايه وكان الامر صعب جدا
استفقنا على اهتزاز المباني بشكل كبير
كانت هذه المره الاولى التي اتعرض لمثل
هذا الموقف وكان الامر صعب وحاولت يعني
بشكل سريع ان اخرج اطفالي ووالدتي وعائلتي
ووجدت معظم السكان اصبحوا في الطرقات في
وضع يرثى له حاله من الرعب حاله من
الارتباك هذا ما رصدناه منذ الصباح الباكر
لهذه هذه المواقف الانسانيه الصعبه التي
شاهدناها في ولايه غازي عنتاب وايضا كما
تشاهدون هناك اعداد كبيره من الاهالي هناك
حاله من التخبط الاهالي لا يعلمون الى اين
يتجهون
هل سيكون هناك هزات ارتداديه ونتحدث عن ان
ابنيه كثيره صدعت ويعني ابنيه كثيره تصدعت
حتى الابنيه التي لم تتصدى
الناس لديه تخوف كبير من الوصول اليها كان
هناك تحذيرات ايضا من الاقتراب من
الاغنياء والصعود الى الابنيه التي تضررت
وايضا هناك يعني عده وسائل تخاطب فيها
السلطات الاهالي هنا من خلال الرسائل عبر
الجوال وتوجه
توجه تحذيراتها وايضا يعني تعطي توجيهاتها
بان هناك تجمعات يمكن للاهالي ان يصلوا
اليها لكن ما نستطيع القول بانه مهما كان
هناك من استعدادات الا ان الكارثه اكبر مع
حديثنا ان جميع الاهالي اليوم هم خارج
منازلهم عمر حوراني عنتاب شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه المعلومات وهذه الصور ايضا مباشره
من هناك